given the current statement obviously
there's lots of contributing different
countries what's going on with
demographics people talk about
population collapse overall globally
what is your view of global population
uh
before we start talking about
deglobalization so assuming that
globalization continues from its height
onward we were already in the process of
revising down our estimates so it used
to be 15 years ago that we thought by
2050 we were going to have 11 to 12
billion people that number is now under
10 and as the data continues to get
upgraded we'll probably
assuming nothing goes wrong Peak at just
below nine and then start falling back
gently
if I'm right about deglobalization we're
going to have a significantly sharper
drop off and as soon as globalization
hits agriculture at large which may be
in the fourth quarter of this year
population Peaks
wow okay positive stuff uh
looking at the ways in which population
collapse and the reduction of that could
be tied in with automation
is there any technological savior that
can come through and assist us with the
problems that we're facing at the moment
there's always unknown unknowns when it
comes to technology I'm aware of that
but are there things that you can
foresee if we get particular
advancements that may alleviate some of
this absolutely so pros and cons uh
there are a lot of Technologies with
automation Ai and Robotics that look
really good now ai the whole idea of
General Ai and Skynet we're decades away
from that so I was put that in the Box
I'll let Elon Musk talk about that AI is
all about image recognition today and
getting it so that machines can
recognize different things and then do
pre-programmed tasks there's no there's
no real autonomy but it's automated
that allows manufacturing to reshape but
it also requires massive economies of
scale the most expensive thing a country
can do isn't industrialized it's to
automate
and it's not a one-off cost you have to
constantly update it because every time
there's a change to the production line
you more or less have to start over with
the programming so it's a very expensive
way to go it does use different labor
and less labor but it's not clear to me
that it really moves the needle in a
huge way and if we're breaking down
Global Transport and intermediate Goods
trade then we're losing the economies of
scale that make that model work
in North America where you've got one
third of global consumption
we'll probably still be doing that but I
see that broadly leaving the East Asian
sphere which combined with their bad
demographics are awful we also have the
Baby Boomers leaving so we know that the
capital crunch is coming that means less
money is available to do this sort of
upgrading
the the technology that I'm most
interested in are the combination of
Automation and agriculture we're very
close to having facilities that you can
latch on to a tractor that identify each
individual plant and identify if it
needs water or fertilizer or pesticide
or if it's weed or whatever and then it
gets a squirt of whatever is appropriate
so you do like six passes of stuff in
one pass and each plant gets individual
attention
that suggests that we would be able to
reduce fertilizer and pesticide use by
80 percent
and maybe even double yields
but again economies of scale it only
works on Mega Farms where you can afford
the equipment cost so if you've got
giant farms in the United States or the
Netherlands or Argentina or Australia
sure
doesn't work for most of the world
talking about technology I've heard that
we are unbelievably reliant on getting
cheap technological Parts out of China
silicon chips and other such stuff how
much of an issue is it going to be if
China is facing demographic collapse and
then can't make anything anymore how
much is that going to have Downstream
effect for the rest of the world's
technology
well we've been a little bit lucky that
the Chinese have kind of become a bag of
dicks and really encouraged everyone to
Outsource and resource everything that
they can uh it's that's bought us a lot
of time now in the United States
everyone is paranoid about
semiconductors and we all see that 12
number that the US now only produces 12
percent of global ships as a panic point
but that's by number
by value we produce 60 percent so all
the leaderships are designed in Japan
the United States they might be
manufactured somewhere else if they're
further down the scale but in terms of
cell phones and server Farms the
important stuff that that's already safe
uh the problem is going to be the mid
and the lower land the mid ones are
usually Malaysian Thailand the lower
ones are almost certainly China
so when you're talking about the lower
text stuff The Internet of Things yeah
that's just going away but I'd argue
that I don't really need a meat
thermometer that is going to tell my
phone what the temperature of the meat
is I mean we can get by without that I
think
it's overall Electronics manufacturer
that's going to be the big issue because
remember differentiated labor forces is
what makes manufacturing work China is a
huge place it's got a lot of that
internally and then it has access
immediately to Taiwan Japan Korea and
Southeast Asia that's what's breaking
down that whole ecosystem
uh we can't rebuild all of that I mean
just just to serve Electronics needs for
North America probably would require a
Workforce of four million people in
manufacturing we're already in labor
shortage and the Mexicans are kind of
tapped out already so there is going to
be a huge amount of pressure Americans
do well at the really high-end
manufacturing and the very low end
because we're energy rich it's the part
in the middle that we're really reliant
on the Mexicans to save us for
what ways could you be wrong about all
of this stuff yeah like I said this is
perspective we're dealing with an
environment that we've never been in
before uh
the way I would like to be wrong is that
the Americans would actually do what
George Herbert Walker Bush wanted to do
back in 1991 and have a conversation
with ourselves about what sort of world
we wanted to live in and how to get
there
we weren't interested then I would argue
that we're really not interested now so
that the risk here from my point of view
is that globalization does manage to
persist because of some lingering
American commitment
I'm not seeing that I'm certainly not
seeing that with Ukraine war yes we're
seeing NATO having a new lease on life
but the whole guns for butter deal that
we made during the Cold War none of the
economic stuff is on the agenda all the
sanctions that the Trump Administration
enacted are still there with one
exception that the Airbus case
ah I don't see it's very likely and then
on the demographic front that's just
math if you want more 30 years 30 year
olds you had to start 31 years ago
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]